is the health secretary matt hancock mr
hancock always a pleasure to see you
thanks for joining us this morning
if it's such a big problem why not
introduce it today
well we need to take this action we've
seen the rise in the number of cases
and we also want to set out very clearly
for everybody
so that everybody has the chance to see
these rules
read them and then to follow them and
that's why it'll come into force
on monday i mean as you've seen k where
there is
where there's a big spike like in bolton
we take action
immediately but the reason is that these
rules are so important
every single person in the country needs
to know what they are
so that we can together keep a grip on
the virus and
and therefore we'll be publishing uh the
details of that
so that everyone has the chance to to
read them
to really understand them with the total
clarity
that we've brought with saying that six
people you can't have gatherings of more
than six people
except in some very limited exceptions
outside of work and of course school um
the northern ireland secretary yesterday
um told us that the government
was prepared to break international law
in a very limited and specific way
why should we abide by the rules
well of course abiding by these rules is
absolutely vital to
to protect life you know we've seen the
increase in the number of cases sadly in
the last
few days we've seen that um
across europe there's a second wave that
that many countries have experienced
some of those countries have then got
that second wave under control if you
look at the
what's happened in belgium they saw an
increase and then they brought it down
whereas in france and spain that just
hasn't happened
and we're determined to take the action
that keeps people safe
and to my point the government is
prepared to break the rules when it
suits you so why should we abide by them
well look on the on the question of the
northern ireland protocol
the the government has a number of
international obligations
and the primary amongst those in this
context
is protecting the peace process that's
about people's safety and security too
in this case in the case of coronavirus
it is
everybody understands how important it
is that
we together keep this under control we
can't do it individually
because of the nature of the disease it
passes on so yes it is incredibly
important
that everybody follows these new rules
and
will be bringing in strict enforcement
so that uh so that so that they can be
followed
uh sarah vine front page of the mail
this morning i'm sure you've seen
however nervous we are we must find the
courage to get on
with our lives she's the wife of the
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
um that's not really helping is it
well okay i think you'd be the first to
say that uh that doesn't doesn't matter
who you're married to
you know people can have different
opinions and so i haven't seen that
actually but
i know sarah very well and she is a uh
she's wonderful and highly opinionated
doesn't really apply to me um as far as
i'm concerned uh health secretary but
nevertheless she is going against
government policy is she wrong
uh look we've absolutely brought these
changes in for a very good reason
and and the reason is that as you can
see in other countries
if you if you have a rise in the number
of cases
and you don't act then that inexorably
leads to more people in hospital
and more people dying of coronavirus
and you know i've been talking obviously
with
with michael gove and others on this
michael is a very strong
supporter of the action that we're
taking today and the reason is really
clear
it's that we need to get through this
coronavirus
with the minimal impact on people's
education
as minimal impact as possible on work as
well
that's why we're exempting education and
work from these new rules but it does
mean that when it comes to
to socializing we are unfortunately
having to put in place rules
because our contact tracing system which
is now excellent
is that shows uh that the majority of
this transmission of this disease is
actually in
in social circumstances okay um you
encourage us as a government young
people to eat out to help out in fact
all of us during august
you have encouraged us to return to work
you've encouraged young people to go
back to school
you've encouraged older young people to
go back to university
and now they are being blamed for a rise
in cases
um they are feeling disgruntled this
morning it's not really surprising is it
uh well i i've we've absolutely
described
where the rise in cases is because i'm
i'm certain that the best way to tackle
this is with
as full transparency as possible about
where the cases are and so
yes we've described that um and um that
all the things you mentioned
it is about bringing back the things
that uh
you know as much as possible whilst
keeping people safe you know it's a
it's a tricky balance but i think people
appreciate what we're trying to
do protect education very very important
protect work
uh because people's livelihoods are
vital to
yet also keep the virus under control
that is
the clear that's the strategy and the
way we do it
is first and foremost with social
distancing and what we're
announcing today is we are having to
tighten those rules for
social distancing in a in a in a social
context in the the socializing that
people do
uh one of the members of independence
sage says the way that you do it is
improve
the uh testing and tracing system and
he's described it this morning on our
program as failing
it certainly isn't uh fit for purpose at
this stage we spoke last week and you
said
you're investing hundreds of millions of
pounds more in order to improve it
still uh we saw a story just in on
twitter yesterday 250 mile
round trip to leicester is the closest
place for a gentleman who needs a covid
test because he lives with his elderly
parents
and many other people just cut one of my
producers this morning checked on the
website
he can't actually get a test because it
says the service is currently very busy
it's failing you have to accept that at
this stage
the test and trace is failing and as far
as testing for covet is concerned
um what do young people do if they need
to have that test if they want to be
responsible as you say
i i completely reject that um the the
fact that it's
that accusation in fact quite the
contrary and if you just
if i just set out why firstly we have
the
biggest testing system per header
population of all the major countries
in europe and we've built it essentially
from scratch
right now we have the highest capacity
for testing that we've
ever had it's increased compared to last
week
and that testing means that we can find
these cases and therefore
um help to keep the virus under control
with the contact tracing system
as well however in the last couple of
weeks we
have seen an increase in demand
including an increase in demand from
people who are not eligible for tests
people who don't have symptoms you are
eligible for a test if you have symptoms
of coronavirus
or if you have a very specific reason
otherwise
and i've been looking into this
including since we talked about it last
week
and we have seen an increase in about 25
percent of people
who are coming forward don't have
symptoms and don't
aren't eligible don't have a reason for
it so we are having to you know
at the moment the system is really very
straightforward because we want to be
easy for people with symptoms to get a
test
um but the message is also clear that if
you're not eligible for a test
if you don't have symptoms or you
haven't been asked to get a test
specifically by a clinician or by a
local authority
then you shouldn't be coming forward to
get a test because
it makes it harder for people who really
need them to get those tests plenty of
people are asymptomatic
how do they know if they've got covert
if they're asymptomatic unless they have
a test
well where the where for instance in
care homes
people are in high risk settings we've
brought in that asymptomatic testing
exactly as you describe
and those people are eligible because
they have been uh told to
get a test but if you are if you're
otherwise asymptomatic like
you or me then there is no reason to get
a test we've had stories of you know
schools sending a whole year group to go
and get a test
um and and that is not appropriate and
what is appropriate
is if you have uh symptoms then get a
test
um the oxford vaccine trial has been put
on hold we're told due to a suspected
adverse reaction
how much of a setback is that for you
health secretary
well it is a it is obviously a a
challenge
to the um to the uh to
this particular vaccine it's not
actually the first time that it's
happened
uh to the oxford vaccine and
it's a standard process within clinical
trials
uh whenever they find something that
they need to investigate
and that's exactly what's happening
happening right now okay but it does it
set us back
on in looking for a vaccine i'm guessing
it does
well not necessarily it depends on the
on what they find when they do the
investigation as i say there has been a
pause
uh earlier in the summer and um and
and that was resolved without a problem
but what it does underline i think kaye
is that when it comes to the vaccine we
will absolutely do everything necessary
to ensure a vaccine is
safe as well as effective and whenever
we find a problem that needs to be
investigated
then we go and then the scientists are
going
and and doing that work so we're always
clear
whilst we're obviously enthusiastic
about how important a vaccine will be
we're also clear that we will only
introduce one when it's safe
and that we will uh
we will go through that proper process
because you know we want to get to a
vaccine that is both safe and effective
as quickly as possible
okay we are out of time but in the
interests of fairness
i did ask you last week about tony
abbott
and you responded in the way that you
did i said he's a homophobe and a
misogynist you said well he's also an
expert on trade
um did you want to add anything else to
that today
well what i'd say is that you know
you could disagree with people on things
and i'm
you know i'm i am nothing if not a
supporter of everybody's
right to live their life how they how
they want to
and um you know mr abbott's
sister actually who is herself
homosexual has come out and said that
those accusations are wrong and i think
we should listen to her words um
very carefully thanks for giving me the
chance to catch up on that subject
sure what about the former uh australian
prime minister who herself said
that he was a misogynist should we
listen to her as well
i i don't i don't know uh i'm not that
close to
uh australian politics uh what i'd say
is that i think listening to somebody's
sister
uh is uh is always a wise thing to do so
if you're not that close to australian
politics how do you know he's going to
be good at trade
come on kay i uh uh i think that
you could see that you we know that he's
uh he's had those responsibilities as
prime minister of australia
and um yeah i am i i vow to nobody in my
support for the values that i hold dear
uh that we should support everybody to
uh to to um to to get the most out of
life and
you know that's at the core of my uh
political beliefs
and and as you know yeah i'm
concentrating uh
uh day and night on uh sorting out this
unprecedented coronavirus
crisis including the news uh this
morning
and um you know it's it's your right to
ask questions about
uh other areas of government but it's
but it's also perfectly reasonable to uh
to answer them uh and listen to the
evidence
that people's for instance people's uh
sisters give
of course but you do come to talk to us
today is collective responsibility as a
member of the cabinet i know that you've
got lots of other people to talk to so
we must let you get on health secretary
thank you
thank you nice to see you thank you